riding the blind horse that's a little
difference but to me it don't make much
difference he's pretty good friends he
just tickled to death to be rode
I think he knows that he's got eyes and
and he just jumps up and down and runs
and really likes to go well my name's
Rodrick Olson
I'm soldier Grove Wisconsin I have
always had a few horses matter of fact
quite a few of them well we got Jackson
about 21 years ago about ten years ago
that we noticed that he was going blind
and in fire we can find out we've
nothing we can do about it mostly old
horse dealers or fire ladies just get
rid of the horse but I figured I'd met
people I'd like to stick around a while
longer so if I went blind oh I hope they
keep me around awhile I didn't figure he
was useless he does everything you want
by the feel of the range he's a little
different
riding than a regular horse he's careful
when he's running you know he ain't sure
where he feets gonna go or what this
front of him but he didn't just quit
because you got blind he's trying to do
things so he can take care of himself
he trusts me to writing I think he just
figures it man I can see now I got eyes
I can do things that I wanted to do for
a long time he watch it run he's fun for
me to ride we go all over the hills down
the canyons in the water everywhere that
any other or can go he does just fine
but he must trust me and well I trust
him he's kind of a buddy anyhow being
friends with a horse that's a I don't
know that's the way I've been with me
all my life
you
[Music]